alors les yeux il aime pas du tout qu'on
lui mette les doigts dans
le robot Buddy est désormais un élève
51ois il a fait sa rentrée scolaire dans
l'agglomération en septembre dernier le
but assister les enfants atteints de
troubles cognitifs dans leur parcours
scolaire
l'expérimentation en classe durera 18
mois
nos amis d'éducation nationale ont
choisi 5 classes des classes de collège
des classes traditionnelles ou des
classes pour accueil d'enfants en
situation de handicap ce qu'on appelle
des Ulis donc 5 classes on s'est lancé
depuis un salon de l'année
donc sur la sur la R&D concernant bien
sûr ses enfants qui ont besoin
bien sûr d'être plus aidé certainement
que les autres conçu par l'entreprise
Blue Frog robotique en 2014 Buddy est
voué à devenir le compagnon des
personnes les plus vulnérables dotées
d'une intelligence artificielle il peut
interagir avec les personnes âgées
isolées ou aidé au développement des
enfants hospitalisés ou en situation de
handicap
entouré d'un réseau d'experts donc des
psychologues des membres d'associations
des personnes autistes etc pour essayer
de cibler au mieux comment répondre à
aux besoins exprimés face à ce qui avait
déjà été fait sur le marché avant
aujourd'hui 2000 robots ont été commandé
par le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il devrait être accessible au
grand public l'an prochain